[Applause]
she's back rise and shine
yeah Kylie Jenner just saying rise and
shine at a drag show and it is
everything let's rewind a bit in October
Kylie took fans on a tour of Kylie
cosmetic headquarters we are here at my
offices my headquarters and this is the
official Kylie cosmetic tour and while
the office was perfectly pink and
gorgeous the real standout moment had
nothing to do with Kylie's workspace
rise and shine
yeah it was that moment Kylie waking up
her daughter stormy with an original
jingle that naturally went viral fast AF
bras and shiny cut to Saturday when
Kylie Chloe Kim and Kourtney as well as
their mom Kris Jenner and her boyfriend
Cory gamble hit up a drag show
[Applause]
[Music]
well at one point during the family
outing Coco took the mic and introduced
her baby sis who blessed us with this
magical musical moment what a day to be
alive
anyway Kylie's momager talked all things
rise and shine during a stop by The
Ellen DeGeneres Show in February you
know what's so funny about that first of
all they said we had no talent I mean
speaks for itself like that's great it
was really amazing the attention that we
got yeah and so by the end of the day I
was like let's burn up some t-shirts you
know why not it's so easy gotta love
that hustle and when et sat down with
Kourt Kim and Chloe they admitted they
love it just as much as everyone else
my last thing I wanted to just say is
fresh and shiny we were laughing so hard
even the other night with her being like
how did this become a thing like this is
so funny to us like all the memes that
they were making
I'm so stupid funny now do you get on
the phone with each other and you're
like rise and shine I do wake up rain
that way in the morning you do and he
loves it where did this come from did
different mom wake you up with rise and
shine is this a family tradition did she
no no I have my good morning song which
I won't sing to you right now are you
sure well that's it for today stick with
ET for all the latest on the
kardashian-jenner z-- until next time
I'm Hallie Stephens and rise and shine
rise and shine
[Music]